le département et antenne réunion vous
présente lien social
[Musique]
avec l'âge se maintenir à domicile peut
s'avérer compliqué il faut alors qu une
solution d'hébergement
les ehpad propose un encadrement social
médical et un environnement adapté à
saint gilles la résidence marie
françoise dupuis accueille plus d'une
centaine de pensionnaires parmi eux
roseanne bénard 81 18 ans elle mène une
vie paisible dans cet établissement
depuis trois ans
[Musique]
alain bénard je veux rentrer bonjour
c'est l'une des résidentes les plus
emblématiques de l'établissement
roseanne bénard 98 vite à l'ehpad de
saint gilles les bains depuis trois ans
dans ma villa à saint denis
j'étais au téléphone j'ai perdu mon
équilibre
impossible de relever ce resserrement
deux heures à six voiliers a pris mes
enfants sont arrivés et l'ont frappé et
crié maman où es-tu mamans venues
alimenter bien enfin monter mais vu le
prix plus élevé
alors donc à fait mavs emmenés chez elle
pendant cinq mois habiter c'est ma fille
mais savez pour moi ça me fait mal parce
que j'ai pu trouver que c'est donner mes
parents ne l'ont pas habiter jamais les
enfants passent et rendre à milan
veulent ils sont jeunes ils ont leur vie
à faire
j'ai dit aux enfants écouter mais
éventuellement quelques places en place
à cet endroit c'est la résidence marie
françoise dupuis à l'ermitage une
structure récente un cadre de rêve très
vite
roseanne s'est senti ici comme chez elle
voyez-les la vue et des magnifiques
couchers de soleil en équateur depuis
trois ans je suis très heureuse monsieur
le directeur est vraiment très très bien
l'équipe sera très très gentil et qui
médical également alors savez ma vie
c'est ma vie et je suis contente
malgré les nombreuses activités que
l'établissement propose c'est dans sa
chambre que cette ancienne institutrice
aime passer ses après midi sa passion la
lecture le moi je lis des livres des
romans qui tous s'accrochent dès les
premières pages
quand j'arrive de celle à qui des
revendeurs à vendredi à déjeuner pour
mon livre j'ai dû arrêter et puis vous
avez dans notre vie dans ma vie j'ai
beaucoup beaucoup voyagé à new york
qu'au canada à montréal aujourd'hui
ces livres sont devenus sa fenêtre sur
le monde des moments d'évasion
presque trop rare au couteau roseanne
car ce ne sont pas les visites qui
manquent
jean-claude vient souvent voir sa mère
et ma photo les toits tous les poilus et
mais sa belle mère ma belle fille qui me
broyait écrit des fois le plus mon dieu
pourquoi mais vous vous déranger mes
enfants des mamans mais lyon peut donne
ma montre en face à 10 ans il dit
pendant soixante dix ans que ma soyez
ont fait la même chose pour cette
famille unie savoir leur doyenne encadré
et épanouie dans la résidence est source
de réconfort aux nous cessera ordinaire
c'est formidable parce qu'on sait
qu'elle en sécurité on sait qu'elle est
bien on sait qu'elle est soignée et on
sait que le personnel autour est très
compétent c'est surtout ce matin vont
penser pas avoir quelques lois de signal
du personnel qui vient d'ailleurs
cherché la résidente aux ânes est
attendu à une petite fête tous les mois
n'est pas d'organiser une journée pour
fêter l'anniversaire de ses
pensionnaires
ici se côtoient des gens venus de tous
les horizons
non pas qu'ils proposent une mixité
sociale puisqu'on a la moitié de mon
book sont habilités à l'aide sociale
il se veut aussi être un complexe
intergénérationnel puisqu'on doit
apporter aux résidences et le préserver
leur autonomie
donc à travers un projet d'établissement
ce qu'un établissement comme le nôtre il
est soumis à autorisation
quand on a une autorisation des tutelles
de la rsl départemental on a différentes
fonctions à travers bien sûr le projet
d'établissement dans lequel vous allez
retrouver le projet soit le projet de
vie le projet hôtelier le projet
d'animation tout ceci d'internet ce
moment le maintien de l'autonomie la
préserver en tout cas et le lien social
qui est indispensable dont ils ont
besoin
le nombre d pad sur l'île est régie par
le conseil départemental et la rs avec
une population vieillissante le
département soutient les projets de
création et d'extension les pas du très
importante parce qu bo la personne elle
est dans l'institution elle est occupée
par un personnel hospitalier elle suit
le salut se sent tout sécuriser le
concernant le traitement des médicaments
notamment concernant l'or pour la
famille bénard plus de tracas si rose
anne a eu une vie bien remplie elle
petit s'y enrichir encore un peu plus
son existence de souvenirs heureux là
donc saluer
et agréable des enfants du paradis pour
voir
[Musique]
à la réunion on dénombre actuellement
1339 places d'accueil en établissement
d'hébergement pour personnes âgées
pour parer au vieillissement de la
population le département soutient les
projets de création d'ehpad 246 places
sont en cours de construction
la collectivité intervient
financièrement sur une partie du
fonctionnement des établissements la
résidence marie françoise dupuis
accueille des personnes âgées valides
semi-valides dépendantes physiquement ou
psychologiquement pour être accueillis
il faut avoir plus de 60 ans et être en
perte d'autonomie
pour plus de renseignements vous pouvez
contacter l'établissement au 02 62 44 44
[Musique]